in
our reading and summary of
z
provisions for the day of reckoning
the promised day the day of the great
appointment
and that these provisions are taken from
the
from the legacy
the ways and the times and the
traditions of the prophet muhammad
we discussed in our previous
session where the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was definitely narrated
to have
looked or focused his vision on
during prayer
we mentioned in the standing position
there is nothing that is
totally authentic and this is why the
scholars
differ on this though
a very strong opinion and it is the
opinion of the author
that a person look to his place of
prostration
where where his forehead or her forehead
would be
in the position of prostration while the
person is in the standing position
in the bowing position
a person's vision should be
towards the ground some scholars
mentioned towards the place of sujud
though it is narrated that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would neither
lift his head nor dangle his head during
bowing and
while a person is in the tashahud
position
sitting in tashahud
then the person's vision should be
focused on his or her index finger of
the right
hand moving it making dua with it
as the prophet salallahu wasallam was
near ready to have done
and the person's focus should be on his
or her finger in this position this is
what was narrated from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
now one of the things that we did not
discuss
is the issue of
where a person
rather what we did not discuss is
whether or not a person is to close
his or her eyes during prayer
this is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholarship of islam
on whether or not it is permissible for
a person
to close his eyes during prayer
this is something that some scholars
view as being something which is
prohibited it is not permissible at all
and they take this ruling and derive it
from the statement of ibn abbas
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
cousin
that the jews
the people of the book it is of their
traits that they close their eyes during
prayer
now what this means is that
the principle the fundamental principle
that islam
settled upon is that
anything that is customary
of the people of the book
it is either to be done opposite
or it is to be done in a modified way
and this is something that a lot of
people don't understand
about the
religion of islam and not just the
religion of islam
but human psychology in general
and that is that a person define himself
if you are not defined if you do not
have a defined
presence if the people of
the religion do not have defined
this is who i am this is who everyone
else
is the person will become lost
and the truth will become diluted
and so at the beginning of
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam's
messengership the focuses
were on commonalities in logic
and religion what does that mean
that we as human beings can all agree
on certain logical points
rhetorically in surah
were they created by nothing from
nothing
or were they themselves the creators of
themselves
or were they the founders and creators
of the heavens and the earth
so these are logical points that
all of humanity can focus on the
prophets and messengers when they come
to a people
they they
speak to them on these logical terms
to establish a bedrock of agreement we
all agree on this
now this is what allah commands
and this is why we find that
when those logical points became diluted
even
logic itself that it was very difficult
to
address them with the oneness of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala because logic
itself had been tainted by these people
and their deviants and so
the point here is that
at the beginning of islam and it's
important that we understand this
progression
at the beginning of islam allah focuses
in the quran
on commonalities of logic commonalities
of religion
meaning that as human beings
we can all deduce and agree that one
plus one
equals two that we are not the creators
we were not created by nothing therefore
there is a creator
is there more than one creator logic
would have it that that is
not possible for two
equal entities to share equal dominion
therefore there is one and if there is
only one then only he
is worthy of worship subhanallah with
that
right and commonalities in religion
such as the people of the book let's go
back to the origins of what our
prophets and messengers all called to
speaking to the christians with what
isaben maryam had
said and spoken to his people and
as well speaking to the people
of judaism with that which their most
prominent prophet
musa moses had said to them
right and
in general when the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam
was a minority of
revelation based
religion meaning in that sense
between the muslims and and the
non-muslims of mecca
they were more close the muslims were
more close and had more in common
with the christians and the jews than
they did with the
pagans of the arabs and so allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala had given a general
rule
and that is
those prophets that have come before you
allah has guided them
and so by their guidance be guided
and so anything that the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam
knew to be of the religion of judaism or
christianity that was practiced by the
people of the book
that was not that he did not find
in what was revealed to him from allah
as something that is prohibited or
something that is an innovation
he and the muslims adopted these things
right and this is
was the way until he made hijab
near the end of his life
when islam became more prominent and
time came
for the muslims to be defined
from every other religion as being the
only truth
then it became that
do the opposite of what the people of
the book do
in the sense that whatever it is that
they do
that is not of your religion
then you are to do its opposite or
if it is definitely something that is of
our religion we do it but we do it in a
modified fashion
what does that mean such as fasting the
day of ashura
right fasting the tenth day of muharram
this is something that the people of the
book did and it's something that is good
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did it
yet at the end of his life he mentioned
that
he was he had intended to fast a day
along with it so either fasting the 9th
and 10th
or the 10th and 11th because this
modifies the act and distinguishes it
from the act of the people of the book
this is the progression rough
progression that took place
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and his companions and so
this idea that we need to just blend in
and this call to the abrahamic
religions
yes we have commonalities with the
people of the book
and we embrace those commonalities of
the worship of allah alone we do believe
in prophets
etc however it is very important
that muslims retain their identity
and this doesn't have to be in the form
of hostility it doesn't mean that we are
hostile towards
jews or christians in that sense what it
means is that we are
defined we are different we
we have different things about us that
set us apart
from the rest of the lot and this is
absolutely necessary
in order to maintain the integrity
of the muslim
community in order that the truth of
islam became
completely unadulterated and clean and
clear
and not diluted with anything else
and so
ibn abbas mentioned that
the jews are it is customary for them to
close their eyes during prayer
hence the companions and and the muslims
and muslim scholarship
in general agree that one should have
his eyes open
during prayer they do disagree on the
ruling
of closing one's eyes during prayer
some view it to be something prohibited
as we have heard from ibn abbas
while others view it to be something
which is makru which is disliked
right and
allah takes a very very good
path in this he says and
and the reason that he says this is that
there's no definitive statement from the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prohibiting this
and obviously this is something that
would have come up
because this is something that is
would be an issue regardless of
the era or time and place right we're
all human beings
should i have my eyes open or closed
during prayer this is something that
the first companions and the last of the
muslims will all have in common
and so being that
this was not directly addressed by the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam meaning that he
explicitly prohibited rather we have
that he did
sallallahu alaihi and he did always
mostly
commonly so we can take from this
that it is disliked
however ibn says
yet if a person is unable to focus
due to some circumstances
let's say they go into a masjid and it's
very fancy or
let's say there's writing on the floor
on the walls or something that is
distracting
or let's say there's sometimes a person
goes to the masjid
and you know back during
normal times there might be children
you know running
around or playing in front of you is
distracting
and so he says if a person is unable to
focus
during his prayer without closing his
eyes
then it is permissible otherwise
it is something which is discouraged
he said and this opinion
is the closest of opinions
to the general principles of islamic law
he says
would often pray barefoot meaning
without anything on his
feet any footwear and
on occasion he would pray in his shoes
or in his footwear right
and there is there are narrations in
which he had
explicitly commanded that
the companions pray in their shoes
because
the jews of medina at that time did not
pray in their shoes
they would always religiously take their
shoes off
and so something that would distinguish
the muslim at that time
would be to wear his shoes during prayer
and so we
we understand the pattern here this
doesn't mean that
all jews during all times everywhere
will
do this right a person may say well look
you know
jews in my community they don't pray
that
right that that is something that may be
different with regards to the time and
place and
these kinds of decisions are reserved
for the jurors
of islam to be able to
take the reality around us
and interpret legislation onto that
reality
either way the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would pray in his shoes and sometimes
not pray in his shoes
what is the qaeda when would he choose
to pray in his shoes and other times not
the answer is
would not change the state that he was
in
to pray so for example
if he wished to make wudu he would not
put socks on to wipe over them if he
didn't have socks on that day
right and vice versa the same thing here
if he had shoes on
and it's appropriate he would pray in
his shoes if he
had shoes off he would not go out of his
way to put shoes on than to
pray right
now some people look to
a verse in surah taha in which allah
subhanahu wa
says to musa
take off your shoes because you are in
the
holy valley of tua which is
and so allah
in that holy place and he also said
later on in the same
chapter in the same line of verses
and establish prayer for my remembrance
and so some people think that this means
that every time i go to pray i need to
take my shoes off religiously and that
is not correct
first of all this is something which is
specific to
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did not
mention
that musa remove his shoes because of
prayer he mentioned for musa to remove
his shoes because of the place
that he was in so for a person to
understand that during prayer
you need to take your shoes off and
understanding that from this verse is a
misunderstanding
he gave as a reason for removing his
shoes
the place that he was in not the act
that he was going to perform which was
prayer that is number one
number two it is something that is
at the level of which is undeniable
and unmistakable that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and his
companions would
pray in the masjid in their shoes
now a person may say well then that
means we need to all
pray in the masjid in our shoes
and of course the way that the massage
it
customarily are
built is that they have carpet and
things that
it's a it's a it's a very internalized
structure if we look at the
prophet sallallahu alaihis at his mosque
we see that the ceiling would leak we
see that
there were no doors that would keep out
wild animals and so forth
we would see that there were no lights
right it was muddy
and the floor was not furnished it was
just
rocks and and dirt right and so
outside and inside is essentially more
or less the same
during that time
however now we have carpet and if we
were to
allow people to enter the masjid even
under those circumstances
with the amount of ignorance that we
have
in the muslim community we would track
in all kinds of
garbage and filth into the masjid and
then a person would be praying in
in filth right so this is an issue of
muslim
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the muslim community was
small
they were vigilant and they were
adhering and dutiful
when the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would say something
immediately it would be put into action
and so the companions of all the allah
if they were told and they were told by
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
if any of you comes to the masjid this
narration is in a sunan
if any of you comes to the masjid
if he has his shoes on he is to look to
the bottoms of his shoes to his souls
and if he finds that they're clean and
clear then he is to
come into the masjid and pray in them
and if not then he is to
rub them off and clean them off in the
dirt
and so immediately the companions all
[Arabic recitation]
and they would be vigilant and they
would encourage one another
and so if any companion saw any stranger
or any person who hadn't heard that come
into the masjid
they would tell him please check your
shoes at the door make sure that they
are clean
however today unfortunately this
unfortunately this is something that
is not practiced if if we were to
implement that part of the sunnah we
would leave off
nine nine tenths
of the other aspects of the sunnah
and though i may digress a bit
it is important that we understand the
difference
that we have to understand the
difference between
people of knowledge and people of
information
okay the verses of the quran
are considered to be all explicit and
clear
but only in one place he says
is all explicit and crystal clear
in the chests of those men who have been
given knowledge and understanding
right and so the people of knowledge
not just people that have facts not just
somebody who's been
reading for two or three years and he
can
you know show us a nice show not young
people who haven't really experienced
much when i mean young i mean
very young in this society 15
16 17 right
in our society the maturity level
is very low so a person may be 20 years
old and have the maturity level of an
eight or nine year old in the time of
the prophet
alaihi and so
the people of knowledge who have
experience
wisdom understanding true correct
understanding they see the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam as an ecosystem
right they see it as an ecosystem what
does that mean
that means that this ruling
in order for it to be completely
correctly
implemented it relies on four or five
other rulings as well they come together
if you remove one the rest are no longer
performed correctly right and so
we have an example of that for example
praying in
in the masjid with your shoes on right
if a person were to if we were to be
sure
that a person's shoes are clean there's
no problem in
praying in the masjid with your shoes on
some people think that this is
blasphemous or sacrilegious that's not
the case
this is fine absolutely no problem so
for example those surgical boots that
you know it's you slip it onto your
shoes and you come in
that's fine there's there's there is no
prohibition of a person wearing his or
her shoes
or footwear in the masjid the reason
that we have shoe racks and we tell
people to take their shoes off etc
is because people
are not as vigilant as they were in the
time of the prophet salallahu
about the message right
and so people will come in and just be
my shoes are good i'm good i'm
fine
right and track all kinds of things into
the masjid
this is something of course which is a
greater
evil than merely not praying in one's
shoes in the masjid
so this is something is very important
for us to understand that the sunnah
a lot of the rulings that were given in
medina
the sunnah it's a a good way to think
about it is a kind of ecosystem
right it's a food chain it it all
links together in a way that
if you remove one or two or three links
it becomes deformed
and it becomes distorted and you're no
longer exactly practicing it
as it was and so we see that today in
our societies we see that in our muslim
communities
that some parts of the religion are held
to
and other parts fall apart and fall away
and then what happens a general weakness
of the muslim personality of the muslim
family of the
muslim individual of the muslim nation
and this is what we have
and this is the reason for that little
things along the way
are left out it's just sunnah it's not a
big deal this little thing here this
little change there this little addition
here
this little subtraction there and
over the course of a few generations the
religion becomes so distorted
that we are back to the days
we will not say the days of ignorance
because the days of ignorance were
abolished by the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
and will never come back as long as the
quran is on this earth
however we will say days of ignorance
right and this is what the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam prophesized
he said in the narration of
islam
he said that islam started out as a very
strange affair
meaning in people's minds and amongst
people and it will go back to being
strange as it once was
would sometimes pray
in one garment
and other times he would pray in two
garments
meaning he would wear clothes with
redundancy to ensure that his
aura his private parts and prayer are
covered concealed properly
and he would usually wear his clothing
with redundancy
and so what does that mean well
if a person is to pray
there are certain parts of the body that
need to be covered during that prayer
right this is what the fukuha refer to
as
a person has a
person has a very strict
aura that no one is to see
other than a person's spouse or intimate
partner
right and that is the
private parts and the majority of the
scholars say
what is between the naval and the knee
for both men and women
then we have another
level of aura which is what a person
must be seen in what a person must wear
during prayer
so a man the bare minimum for a man to
wear during prayer
is from his navel including his navel
include to below his knee and
his shoulders right and his shoulders
this is the bare minimum now just
because something is
minimally accepted doesn't mean that it
is appropriate
i mean obviously if a person came to the
masjid
you know with with
wearing a pants on his navel to his
knee
and threw a scarf on his neck
and came to the masjid while this is
permissible
it's not haram it's also not appropriate
right and that's another distinction
that we'll make later
and for ladies for women
in the opinion of the fukuha of islam
all of them all of the scholars
the four scholars the four imma hanifa
malik
all of them agree that the bare minimum
for a woman to
cover outside of her home
meaning where strangers strange men of
the opposite sex may see her
is that everything must be covered
except for her hands and her face
right this includes the feet
the only time abu hanifa rahimahullah
disagreed with the feat
is in saleh only only in salah
so if a woman is in her house alone in
the madhhab of
hanifa she doesn't have to cover her
feet but this again
is a not a very strong
opinion and the rest of the scholars of
is of
the medeb and the other three
imams of the form of
agree that the feet should be concealed
during prayer as well
and this is the exact fatwa
of
that she was asked what should a woman
wear
during her prayer she said
she used to wear a head garment that
covers
right covers dangles from the head and
and
yes
and to wear a dress that will completely
cover her body
including the tops of her feet this is
what
her answer was
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in order for prayer to be acceptable
in order for it to be valid one of the
conditions of prayer
is that a person's
i would be covered during the prayer and
so
often times one may be enough
but the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would wear two garments
for redundancy to ensure that nothing
would show
right there is a weak narration
that mentions that purports that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
may allah have mercy on the women that
wear pants
this means that they wear pants under
their clothing
they wear their dresses they wear
their
and as an additional portion of
redundancy to ensure their their
their dignity remain intact and that
they not
show anything that they wear pants as
well but that's something that wasn't
common in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi for men or women
the narration is weak but if it were
authentic that's what it means
it doesn't mean some bab
[Silence]
scholars who
wish to appease the masses and they
interpret the texts and other than what
was intended
they said no is it permissible for a
woman to go out in public wearing pants
yeah there's no problem rahim alone
this heather had a had a lap
film this is
playing games with what the prophet
salallahu salem intended he never
intended that a woman can wear a pair of
pants and walk out in public
rather what was meant by this narration
it's not authentic but if it were
that's what it means as a as an action
as an act of redundancy
not that it's okay for a woman to wear
pants outside
the point here is that a person must
cover these parts of his or her body
during prayer
for the man the bare minimum is the two
shoulders the attack this is the
shoulder had the whole
in the arabic language
what is between the shoulder
and the neck this is called the attack
right this part this has to be covered
during prayer for a man
right
and so many people don't know this
many people say this is strange this is
weird
any lots of people
grow up watching temptilia till islamiy
wearing just the pants and you know
walking around
without anything on his body
this is incorrect rather
in sahih al-bukhari and now in certain
terms the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
[Silence]
a man is not to pray in a garment which
does not
cover his shoulders he said sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this narration is
collected by
and so
this is the bare minimum for men
the bare minimum for women
is everything from head to toe
except for the hands
and the face the hands at the wrist
right and the face this this can be
uncovered during prayer and
in the correct opinion outside in public
as well
right and
the scholars of islam mention
that there are eight
conditions for a woman's hijab
and some of those conditions are shared
by muslim men as well
and one of those conditions for the
validity of a man's prayer
aniyakuana
that the garment that the man is wearing
or the woman is wearing
that it is thick enough that it is not
transparent meaning that you wear
something that is see-through
as we say right
now what is the meaning of transparent
ish mana
[Silence]
that when a person puts this garment on
you cannot see the color of the pigment
of their skin
that is the minimum amount of thickness
right so what does that mean so for
example
let's say a phobe what we call a though
that's white you know it's made out of
thick material
but if i put a t-shirt on and the
t-shirt has a picture or writing on
it and i put that over it you can still
see it through there
right this is considered
the laser catheter
and so if it is something that you can
see the color
of the skin this here for example
you cannot see the if
no matter what the color of my skin is
or what i'm wearing underneath you
cannot see through it
however there are garments t-shirts and
light clothing especially the color
white that
there needs to be redundancy
meaning that if you're going to wear
this white soap you need to wear one
t-shirt under it that will
reinforce and become redundant so that
the color of the skin does not show
this is the bare minimum of a
thickness that will not define the color
another condition is
[Silence]
right meaning that it is
thick enough that it is not transparent
and that it is
baggy enough that it does not define
right for example
a woman or a man to wear spandex or
tights or something this this is
basically
this has the ruling of not
existing in islamic law
right it used to be just a woman
you know just women in our
this society here that would wear this
kind of thing
be very skinny jeans or very tight
clothing
right and it would define the
body parts this is not considered
set of the laser center on her that is
does not
conceal this beautifies
right but now unfortunately the new
thing
is that guys are doing this as well
right so now we have the problem with
men as well
wearing skinny pencil jeans and you know
wearing
clothing that is too tight and these
pants or these
whatever it is is so tight that it
defines
the shape of the body underneath this is
something which
is not permissible during prayer as well
[Silence]
is
was narrated to have made dua this is
called
is that a person make dua
after the bowing
after they raised from that final record
the final record of the sale
so in fajr it would be after the second
report
in it would be after the fourth report
that when he raises up between going
to sujud and raising from rukur
he would raise his hands and make dua
this is called
it was narrated authentically
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam made this dua for one month
right and then he stopped making this
dua
[Silence]
this is only employed during some
calamity some
crisis that has befallen the people and
it's not
only fragile it's all of the five
prayers
right in this particular instance
is
[Silence]
and so this dua that he would make
he made it for a month after fajr and
then he stopped
and this continued
due to some crisis that may be fall
right
[Silence]
which his sunnah settled upon was that
he would make this dua in the five
prayers
after the final report
only in times of grave
circumstances or crises right let's say
there is a hurricane coming or tornadoes
right
or let's say there is a great earthquake
that
or a tsunami or some kind of terrible
thing that happens
it's a general thing right it happens to
the
community of your place at large
and it affects everyone this is what is
referred to as a nozzle
and during these times of crisis
it is the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that the imam
lead the people and make dua so
the question now arises who makes the
decision
of whether this is a nozzle or not right
because this is used often as well for
political reasons just like
everything else has been hijacked in
islam by certain people
and so
forth
[Silence]
so this is something that is to be
determined by the
people of knowledge of any particular
area or place
and so based on this we understand that
perhaps
we would be making dua el canute in
chicago
and people in wisconsin are now making
dual notes because it's something that
affects our particular community
something happened here locally
right so this is something that has to
be kept
in in mind
[Silence]
would not make this type of dua only in
fajr rather it's in all of the prayers
as we mentioned
but he would emphasize
his dua during fajr right
so maybe they would be
and the reason for this is that
is the most recognized most
likely for
a dua to be accepted by allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
and it has been authentically reported
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
i am merely a human being as you all are
human beings
and i forget just as you all forget
anibal
[Silence]
foreign
my
[Silence]
and so if i forget something then remind
me
i am a human being as you all are human
i forget
as you all forget so if i forget
something never mind
that's what he says
and it was actually a great blessing
from allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that he was made to forget certain
things
yet
he says
and that is that it is a blessing from
allah that
he shares these common human
traits with us so that we are able to
better follow him and do as he did
under these circumstances
he says an example
of his forgetfulness this is not
something that
he is a forgetful person it's just that
no matter who you are
you will eventually forget right
it was mentioned that imam ahmad ibn ham
as perfected as his
memory was in the memorization of the
prophet salallahu's narrations
[Silence]
one of the examples of this is that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
narrated this narration is
a muslim that he had
forgotten and
made tesleem and ended his prayer
and it was salatopur at the second
recap rather than the fourth
so instead of making four rakah he made
two
made tesleem everybody made to sleem
with him some people left
other people asked him that we're in the
front row
did you forget or has a change been made
in alteration
been made to sha allah next week
me